je suis will robinson colons de la 24e
mission je filme ce qu'on est en train
de faire parce qu'il semblerait qu'on
soit les premiers humains a tenté de
transformer en vaisseau spatial en
bateau à voile
on se perd flou
[Musique]
c'est une cascade
est ce qu'un jour on pourrait arriver où
on veut sans se cacher il faut
s'arracher des wings
je vous aime tous
[Musique]
tu es en train de penser au robot moi
aussi je voudrais qu'il soit là on doit
le retrouver
il faut qu'on essaye au mans ce rebond
est la clé de notre survie à tous
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce machin
vous pouvez passer tout le monde ils
sont tous partis tu sais pourquoi le
monstre qu'on pille un petit truc là
on dégage au plus vite et on oubliera
tout ça
il faut qu'on pense à notre survie
[Applaudissements]
une vie normale nous attend quelque part
faut juste qu'on la trouve c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît j'ai rien à faire moi
votre boulot c'est de rester là et de ne
toucher à rien elle supporte pas que
quelqu'un d'autre soit l'héroïne du jour
toi et tes soeurs et votre mère
[Musique]
vous protéger mutuellement
m
si vous voulez robin 104 g reçoit
mesdames
à
on est vraiment obligé de faire sa mue
mme robinson